[Applaudissements]
kenny on a retrouvé votre première
phrase déjà comme vous avez été engagée
alors dit on s'est rencontré à ailleurs
dans un club libertin non faire
approuver sur le plateau de la funa
poule a c'est vrai les projets
d'aménagement c'est un beau but donc
voilà donc c'était comme ça tu es invité
elle se la péter non mais sérieux alors
je sais pas si elle c'est la pj oui
alors je vais bien préciser alors parce
qu'elle m'a pas parlé de toul adulte
avant le tournage elle m'a pas parlé
pendant l'émission il m'a parlé à peine
et après le tournage elle s'est barrée
direct alors si je peux préciser un vrai
ou pas non j'ai pensé la même chose de
vous je suis partie le voir après
l'émission juste voir une petite photo
pour mes réseaux sociaux il m'a dit
ouais allez vas-y à dépêche toi le
vernis craque et ba et ba semblait
devoir être une comédie romantique ça qu
on avait été stationné
voilà ce jour là il était énervé il
s'excusait quoi c'est vrai ouais si non
mais c'est vrai c'est étonnant je
faisais un caractère constant à jour
à l'est pas du tout ce pôle et du tout
[Rires]
ensuite deux ans après j'ai fait une pub
avec benjamin castaldi one way et donc
je pense que c'est à ce moment là que
vous avez demandé mon numéro avait dit
ouais mais bon et envoyer un message et
vous m'avez dit donc sans signer sans
rien est ce qu'on peut se voir août à
autre chose à [ __ ] ça nous j'ai
entendu cinq minutes parce que je me
suis dit c'est qui ce ouf
ouais et vous avez écrit c'est cyril
âgées au prix j'ai appelé aurore la
femme de benji et je lui dis ah ben je
crois qu'il ya cadenas qui m'envoie un
message
qu'est ce que je fais aujourd'hui data
lesquelles celle où cette histoire est
ca pardon mais je ne sais pas ce qui
nous manque des élèves c'est comme ça
qu'on peut dire t'as vu une pendant sa
vie est ce qu'on peut se voir cyril tu
pense tout de suite à un une à tien
c'est marrant tu l'as vu une fois dans
ta life jamais voilà
oui bien sûr indécent et je les ai vus
au bureau avec le dal stan voilà le dg
ça s'est très bien passé
voilà il depuis elle est là vous
rappeler votre première ouais bah
c'était y'a pas si longtemps cette faute
là regardez là vous savez dans une pub
pour timothée sans déconner alors qu'ali
vous êtes de bonne ou de mauvaise humeur
très bonne humeur pour calibrer ahmad
taylor swift en ce moment ah ouais ouais
c'est quoi laquelle peut vous le passé
je t'aimerai remettre balesi on n'a que
ça à [ __ ] sais pas si vous êtes dj
tout
on a fait
[Applaudissements]